Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
We have talked about fluid and cloth simulations
earlier, but we never really set foot in the
domain of hair simulations in the series.
To obtain some footage of virtual hair movement,
simulating the dynamics of hundreds of thousands
of hair strands is clearly too time consuming
and would be a flippant attempt to do so.
If we do not wish to watch a simulation unfold
with increasing dismay as it would take hours
of computation time to obtain just one second
of footage, we have to come up with a cunning
plan.
A popular method to obtain detailed real-time
hair simulations is not to compute the trajectory
of every single hair strand, but to have a
small set of strands that we call guide hairs.
For these guide hairs, we compute everything.
However, since this is a sparse set of elements,
we have to fill the gaps with a large number
of hair strands, and we essentially try to
guess how these should move based on the behavior
of guide hairs near them.
Essentially, one guide hair is responsible
in guiding an entire batch, or an entire braid
of hair, if you will.
This technique we like to call a reduced hair
simulation, and the guessing part is often
referred to as interpolation.
And the question immediately arises: how many
guide hairs do we use and how many total hair
strands can we simulate with them without
our customers finding out that we're essentially
cheating?
The selling point of this piece of work, is
that it uses only 400 guide hairs, and leaning
on them, and it can simulate up to a total
number of 150 thousand strands in real time.
This leads to amazingly detailed hair simulations.
My goodness, look at how beautiful these results
are!
Not only that, but as it is demonstrated quite
aptly here, it can also faithfully handle
rich interactions and collisions with other
solid objects.
For instance, we can simulate all kinds of
combing, or pulling our hair out, which is
what most researchers do in their moments
of great peril just before finding the solution
to a difficult problem.
Not only hair, but a researcher simulator,
if you will.
The results are compared to a full space simulation,
which means simulating every single hair strand,
and that is exactly as time consuming as it
sounds.
The results are very close to being indistinguishable,
which was not the case for previous works
that created false intersections where hair
strands would erroneously go through solid
objects.
We can also stroke bunnies with our hair models
in this truly amazing piece of work.
These episodes are also available in early
access for our Patreon supporters.
We also have plenty of other really neat perks,
I've put a link in the description box, make
sure to have a look!
Thanks for watching, and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!